si dieu ne décide pas de ta mort alors
tu reste en vie la mort saliou l'a vu de
près comme lui ils sont des centaines à
tenter leur chance à chaque traversée au
départ du port de hambourg l'un des
principaux points de départ des migrants
pour les canaris avec son frère fin
octobre ils ont embarqué sur une pirogue
dont le moteur a cassé sur 200 passagers
ils ne sont que 51 avoir survécu
le feu n'était pas trop fort lorsqu un
bidon d'essence a explosé
j'ai laissé mes bagages je me suis jeté
à l'eau certains passagers qui ne savait
pas nager se sont agrippés à moi nous
avons nager nager et autour de nous les
gens se noyait c'était terrible
un phénomène qui ne date pas d'hier et
qui a été accentuée par la crise
économique puis celle du co vie de 19
pour une traversée chaque migrant doit
payer entre 300 et 500 euros à des
passeurs
nous avons dénombré plus de 400 cas pas
mes mots vous imaginez les hommes les
jeunes à paul delage qui devrait
constituer le plus elle est le parent 8
et du coup ils ont gaspillé comme ça le
vit sûrement changer comme ça l'a vu des
conditions qui n'empêche pas les
candidats à l'exil de continuer à rêver
depuis janvier près de 18000 personnes
auraient rejoint les canaris selon
l'organisation internationale pour les
migrations
en plus de la crise bourg ville de
pêcheurs est minée par la concurrence
avec des licences attribuées d'abord aux
navires européens et chinois beaucoup
mieux équipés
au fil des années est heureux on part en
mer et à notre retour
ce qu'on gagne couvrent à peine ce qu'on
a dû dépenser il n'y a rien pour nous
ici et c'est pour cela que nous
préférons tout quitter pour partir c'est
la seule manière d'aider nos parents
notre famille légué voulu impressionner
nos terres de son iphone
une parade à ces derniers mois 500
personnes seraient mortes en tentant la
traversée
un voyage d'environ 1500 km qui peut
durer de sept à dix jours
le gouvernement tente selon lui des
actions dissuasives
les plus du jour les équipes sont sur le
terrain que ce soit ici à vous c'est lui
coulant le sud pour essayer d'identifier
d'abord le nombre de jeunes qui sont
partis le nombre de rescapés et le
nombre de
personne potentiellement candidats au
départ l'état aussi en train de mettre
en place des outils qui vont auditionner
les jeunes de partir notamment en
arrêtant les passeurs car il faut le
dire le mot ce sont des criminels et il
faut les traiter comme tel selon des
estimations
seule une pirogue sur trois arriverait
aux canaries mais l'exode massif
persiste une réalité qui contraste avec
les promesses de créations d'emplois du
président macky sall dans ce pays de 16
millions d'habitants
20 % des 15-24 ans sont au chômage